RULES COMMITTEE FOR THURSDAY
AUGUST SIXTEENTH A SHARP Y.
CALLED ORDER.
PLEASE.
AN AUTOMATIC RECORDING TODAY'S
PROCEEDINGS BE MADE IN THIS ALSO
BEING TELEVISED.
AHMED SECTOR FISCAL COOLEY HERE.
CARILLO.
SOME PROGRESS HERE GALLAGHER
GRAYSON THEIR KAMLAGER-DOVE UP
HERE.
MAYES HERE NAZARIAN PRESENT
SALAS WALDRON HERE FROM HERE
REFORM.
WE HAVE A QUORUM.
OF WE HAVE A CONSENT AGENDA.
WYMAN FORMER THERE'S A REQUEST
FOR MARC COLLEAGUES OF MR FUNG
YOU WANT TO PRESENT THAT.
I WAS TREMENDOUS RESPECT WHERE
REQUEST REMOVAL CONSENT ITEMS.
I NUMBER THIRTEEN EMERGENCY
CROTCH REQUEST FOR S. P..
SEVENTY NINE I WAS REQUESTED
MOVING CONSENT ITEM FIFTEEN THE
JOINT.
RULE SIXTY ONE B. WAIVER I
REQUEST TO HAVE A SEPARATE VOTE
ON SO MINUS THOSE TWO ITEMS AND
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN WE HAVE OUR
CONSENT AGENDA.
SO IS OUR MOTION UNDER MAJOR
CONSENTED.
OF MOVES AND MISS CARILLO
SECONDED BY MISTER NECESSARY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT SECTOR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL COOLEY.
AYE COOLEY AYE CARILLO.
CARILLO.
GRAYSON AYE GRAYSON AYE
KAMLAGER-DOVE.
KAMLAGER-DOVE AYE MAYES.
MAYES AYE NAZARIAN.
AYE NAZARIAN AYE SALAS WALDRON
AYE WALDRON AYE FONG AYE FONG
AYE MUCH.
MOTION PASSES IS OUR MOTION ON
ITEM THIRTEEN THE CURSOR REQUEST
FOR S. B..
SEVEN FIFTY NINE MOVE I MISS
CARILLO SECONDED BY MINUTES
KAMLAGER-DOVE --
BENEFIT OR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
COOLEY I COOLEY AYE CARILLO AYE
CARILLO AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE GALLAGHER GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE YEAH.
KAMLAGER-DOVE OF AYE MAYES NO
MAYES NO NOS AREA.
NAZARIAN AYE SALAS WALDRON
THOUGH WALDRON NO FONG.
FONG NOW MOTION PASSES.
VERY GOOD THAT MOTIONS PASSED IS
OUR MOTION ON ITEM.
FIFTEEN MOVE BY MS GROSS SECOND
REMISSION IS AREA.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MA'AM
CENTER PLEASE CALL THE ROLL%
SCHOOLING BY COOLEY AYE KOREA
AYE SHARIA AYE CERVANTES AYE
CERVANTES AYE.
GALLAGHER GRAYSON.
GRAYSON AYE KAMLAGER-DOVE YET
[inaudible]
MAYES.
THOUGH IT MAY NOT [inaudible]
THERE AND IN THIS AREA AND I
SALAS WALDRON.
WALDRON NO PHONE NO.
NO FISSION PRODUCTS.
DIRECTOR OF THE MOSIS PASSED AND
THIS RULES CRAZY.
COM